but um yeah but that that show it was
everything and also it was also hell for
me but um yeah but I met you and you
were so nice to me and you Alex Borstein
and we'll were the only three people
that really kind of like set stuff past
hello you know like oh how are you doing
you know that is I have to say that is
appalling why because I don't well I'd
certainly don't want to think badly of
the people that were like you don't have
to remember when it came on there was
two lawsuits going on well no there was
a you're right yeah there was yeah
there's a bunch of lawsuits going on
yeah yeah and then so crazy people you
can tell people you walk in a room you
can tell that people didn't like certain
people but not just like they're like it
was like an obvious uncomfortable
feeling of like something's going on
here that's wrong and then no and when
you're new and no one's talking to you
you you all you you perceive it as your
it's your fault like all the key to all
of it right now you show up and you're
like this is my reality I did this which
is crazy yeah I can see that you know I
do have a need to make people feel
comfortable
yeah yeah yeah and so it's like any new
person that came in I like to think that
I reached out you were so nice you know
to because it's hard to come in to a
situation like that and we were so
intense and we were a family like each
other or lump each other
do you know what I mean it's like it was
an intense environment to come into and
so I always wanted to be like it's okay
you think come on in and play yeah but
you know it shows you people though
right it's like Will Sasso to was nice
yeah and you're the you're the only one
aside from will that's done this podcast
Jordan I know but
from that later yeah when I that way
later in that class yeah wow you're the
only two right that says a lot
yeah yeah no it isn't a nice if I think
about who like who who am I still in
contact with yeah I can tell you it's
it's it's limited yeah you know Debra
Wilson and I have remained lovers
sisters I got to get her on this yes you
know Will Sasso well forever was Aries
already on this yeah yeah Aries and I
are in contact yeah yeah you know it's
like probably we can edit this out if we
want yeah see what he wrote about us
know what he said about how [ __ ] well
you were a big [ __ ] coward and how
you weren't real and there's nobody real
in the industry and he just went on a
[ __ ] is that
I think someone asked Aries oh yeah like
hey are you gonna be on Tiger belling's
like that [ __ ] won't return my
tax our call it sexy but here's here's
the [ __ ] have you been on his no Touche
does he have one yes yeah so there you
go
but that's uh here's the thing all right
he has to do mine ten times in a row in
one day right yeah so is the psyche
that's an do you know I have a schedule
we only do it once a week you know yeah
and then he's like pop me you know like
pump me for these other people and then
I went that kind of like and made me
more defensive yeah and then um now is
different around here
that's so funny to me though it's so
much easier to be kind
[Music]